[Musique]
je dois jouer je dois jouer de la
musique la musique c c'est plus qu'une
part de moi c'est ce que je suis dans ma
vie je suis triste je prends ma guitare
je laisse à chacun le droit d'écouter sa
raison et moi je n'écoute
[Musique]
avez vous déjà eu ce sentiment est trop
haut ce qu'une chanson et fait
spécialement pour vous de passer tout
l'été
[Musique]
son projet
encore plus fort les plus pauvres
ne sous-estimez jamais le pouvoir de la
musique c'est à venir
personne ne pouvait me l'ouvrir c'était
à moi peindre ce rêve devient crochet de
toutes mes forces et nbc vue
[Musique]
et qui est là je suis désolé
qu'est ce qui se passe je suis entraîné
à a
[Musique]
faut rester avec moi mon chien ou tu pas
au ou mai
c'est pas un rêve vous êtes vraiment
tout cela
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]